for the first time in four decades the
U.S army unveiled a wholly new armored
Fighting Vehicle the M10 Booker it has a
fully traversable turret it is armed
with a 105 millimeter main gun some Army
officials have called it a new light
tank but many say the mission and
protection of the booker is very
different from a tank here's how it
compares to tanks like the Abrams which
the US is sending to Ukraine and why the
Army has invested more than one billion
dollars to equip itself with this new
vehicle
[Music]
the booker looks very similar to the
Abrams both are fully tracked vehicles
with a four-person crew 360 degree
turret large caliber main gun and a
Commander's independent thermal viewer
that allows visibility at night and in
multiple directions but the booker is
just over half the weight of the latest
Abrams tank the battlefield role for the
M10 will be to support deployed infantry
forces the booker basically gives you
armor support that you would not have
otherwise had it can carry a wider
variety of Munitions it can go places
that an up armored Humvee can't go
tracked Vehicles distribute weight more
effectively for better off-road
performance and and the Booker's road
wheels are even lighter than previous
tracked vehicles of a similar size this
allows it to move easily to and around
the battlefield a common choke point for
heavier tanks like the Abrams there will
be bridges for example that could
support a Booker but not support an
Abrams it all means the booker can be
deployed by aircraft relatively easily
rotate for the 31 M1A1 Abrams promise to
Ukraine delivery could be one of the
biggest challenges only one Abrams can
fit inside this C-17 globemaster
compared to two Bookers
but in order to get a vehicle in this
weight class the Army had to be more
strategic about the level of armor just
look at the turret on the booker
compared to the Abrams you see from the
roof on the turret in particular is
actually armor the turret connects the
gun to the main body of the vehicle the
turret front is usually thought to be
the part of the vehicle that is most
likely to be hit by an enemy Abram's
turret is very well protected Booker's
turret is probably fairly well protected
but the expectation is not there that it
would be as survivable as Abrams even
with less protection the booker does
bring new capabilities to infantry
forces with its main gun a nearly 105
millimeter cannon
that's smaller than the Abrams 120
millimeter main gun but more powerful
than the 25 millimeter cannon on the M2
Bradley it gives you the flexibility of
firing projectiles that are specifically
designed to penetrate armor and the
booker also comes equipped with a highly
accurate targeting system essentially on
each of these vehicles you have a
computer that computer can be used to
detect the range to the Target using a
laser and it can calculate where to fire
the gun to hit a Target including if
it's moving and including if you're
moving but less armor might also explain
a key difference between the two engine
placement in the case of the booker that
would mean that the engine sits in front
of the crew and potentially provides
additional protection to them so if the
vehicle is hit from the front then there
is a chance that the crew would be more
likely to survive a hit Abrams simply
just has a great deal of front armor it
balances it by having the engine at the
back compared to the Abrams gas turbine
engine burning like 12 gallons of fuel
an hour just to be turned on the
booger's 800 horsepower diesel engine is
meant to extend the fuel time for a full
24 hours
when the vehicle is idling it will burn
much less fuel all of these factors
weight armor main gun and engine play
into how the two differ in deployment
the booker is not necessarily designed
to go toe-to-toe with an enemy's heavy
armor top tier main battle tanks
adversary armored vehicles are not what
you would want a Booker for this is why
we have Abrams and the armor Brigade
combat team the armored Brigade combat
team is considered a heavy Force the
booker on the other hand is meant to
work with the ground troops or the
Infantry Brigade combat team military
experts say this team is designed for
quick deployment and is able to operate
in highly restrictive terrain like
Jungles forests mountains and cities the
advantage of infantry is that they can
go lots of places they have lots of
ability to see things they can sneak
around more effectively if you are
fighting in an environment that is very
difficult terrain they can then
communicate where the most dangerous
targets are to your tank
and the crew members operating this
vehicle will find it rather familiar
because both the booker and the Abrams
are made by the same company General
Dynamics land systems so they do share
some features in helpful ways were told
that they have similar controls for the
crew members these shared
characteristics will allow for more
seamless training it will be very
familiar to tankers who will basically
use similar crew drill and both the
booker and the Abrams have
compartmentalized ammunition which is a
design intended to protect the crew if
the ammunition explodes
this is what helps these vehicles avoid
the Jack-in-the-Box explosion seen with
many Russian tanks during the war in
Ukraine where ammunition stored around
the turret exploded likely killing the
crew and causing the turret to fly off
but the arrival of the booker comes at a
time when new challenges have Arisen for
tanks and combat Vehicles alike modern
armored vehicles can be attacked from
literally any direction right now in
Ukraine vehicles are worrying about
artillery and drones that might attack
the top of a vehicle they have to deal
with mines that would attack the bottom
of a vehicle and of course direct fire
threats can come from any direction the
Army grew interested in building a
vehicle like the booker just years after
Russia's annexation of Crimea with
experts noting the need for more mobile
protected Firepower in light of modern
Russian Warfare but actually making the
booker a reality hasn't been cheap last
summer General Dynamics was contracted
for the production and Fielding of
nearly 100 vehicles in a 1.14 billion
dollar deal before extending the
contract to include an additional 26
vehicles and adding another 258 million
dollars
but the vehicle has run into issues
early tests found high levels of toxic
fumes when firing the main gun the Army
has pretty high expectations of how
ready a vehicle should be when it
reaches soldiers if there's any issue
with Soldier safety problem with the
fumes from the main gun which they
actually have dealt with according to
the office that works the acquisition on
this they'll have to deal with that
before they can green light production
the first unit of M10 Bookers is
expected toward the end of 2025. each of
those systems is expected to cost around
13 million dollars with plans for the
cost to go down as production increases
this price doesn't perfectly compare to
the estimated 10 million dollar Abrams
because unlike the Abrams the booker is
a new build the difference between the
newest version of Abrams and the
original version of Abrams is night and
day
Abrams literally got a gun upgrade a
different main gun installed when it
went from the M1 to the M1A1 but this
first iteration of the booker fills an
important Gap in the Army's capabilities
and is intended to serve as a long-term
solution when this thing is fielded
there will almost certainly be then
subsequent changes you give a vehicle
like this to a bunch of soldiers and
they will find ways to break it that you
need to fix and they will find things to
improve about it that will then go back
up through the Army and ultimately
hopefully turn into a Booker A2 that is
a better version
[Music]
foreign